Kayla you and I have a bit of a history
and I think we should come clean uh
recently on a trip to New York I take
trips to New York to uh
do some podcasts other business and I
was walking in the street with my good
friend of many years one of my oldest
friends Eric Rife
and I think we were near Moma is that
right Kayla
very near mama you were almost inside
the museum yeah
I tried to go inside but was immediately
escorted out most good museums they know
the scoop and they escort me out
immediately but Kim and I you and I had
an interaction and we chatted for a
little bit and it was interesting
because I think maybe uh
the essence of me
came out in this introduction is that
fair to say
all the Contours of your personality
were there yeah okay well I'm going to
take that as a compliment even though it
really isn't something no and I remember
we chatted for a little bit and I I one
of the things I had to do was an upfront
where there's an audience and I actually
recounted my interaction with Kayla in
front of this audience and it got a big
laugh and you've talked about this on
the Regular Show as well exactly you
want to do a brief recap yeah briefly
run into Kayla she uh professes anyway
to be a fan of the podcast we chat
briefly and then I thought usually
people would like to commemorate it with
a
um
selfie and I said would you like a
selfie and she said no I'm good
uh and
um my friend thought that was really
funny uh me less so no I I and then I
said uh
I don't know I think I I didn't let it
go immediately the idea of the selfie
and then you didn't I think not well
Kayla you were there I think Kayla you
were there and you were here today yes
Taylor as though as the witness and you
mentioned that um that this need to
please neediness that's in the title of
the podcast came out in that moment is
that what happened yeah I wanted to let
you go first so that I could give the
honest account of what happened because
it was a little different than that but
um all right
um very similar no I'm an enormous fan I
love you guys I listen every week I've
been a fan for years and I was leaving
work at this unusually late hour I'm
normally not there around dinner time
and I was on the phone with one of my
best friends Olivia and I was walking
out of the staff kind of exit and I'm in
the revolving doors and I see this
person peering in
um
and I got out and I'm in my head I'm
like you've got to be kidding me so I
said to my friend just hold hold on a
second and then I turned to you and I
just I wanted to say how much I love
your work and the show and
um and you were so generous and kind and
standing you know there to talk to me
and everything and then you said so do
you want to take a selfie to to show
your friends and I felt at that point
like I was already such an imposition
having stopped you guys you were looking
for the modern which is the restaurant
at the Museum can I stop you for one
second and say when I was peering in
yeah we were there's a restaurant uh
in the museum or adjacent to museum or
associated with the museum called the
modern right
yes and so
my friend Eric said I think this is the
restaurant and I was peering in through
the glass now of course you just see a
tall creep peering in at you as you're
trying to exit the building I was
looking to see is this where the
restaurant is so I'm clearing that up
first of all uh it's interesting you
left that out though when you were first
telling the story well I I often peer
that doesn't make it better I'm someone
who peers to see what's going on inside
and uh and and I like to peer and I like
to furtively look around
uh and you know but um anyway that's
what happened so we had a nice chat I
thought maybe and then you thought that
was too much of a imposition on me
yeah I I don't I never I didn't want to
impose I sort of I like blacked out as
soon as I saw you because I'm you're
literally my hero and I didn't no I I
didn't remember anything that I said in
that moment so I said I guess what I
said was
um
I'm good and then that's not really my
style and then your face just totally
fell and I felt I really wanted a
picture with you it made me I felt
really sad and then I said why do you
want a selfie and then
it's so and then you said yeah I really
do oh I do it's true oh and so then you
still didn't take a selfie with him well
actually I think you blacked out too
because oh we did get a selfie
okay so here's the crazy part so you're
so happy in that picture I am happy
because I finally got the selfie you're
on a reimagining of this made you think
of it the worst possible scenario that's
what often happens yeah yeah I um
my inner voice is quite negative but uh
we did eventually get the selfie but
then Kayla you're leaving out the real
Oh Henry twist
which is
several weeks later I'm back in New York
to do these other podcasts
and I hear oh hi Conan and it's Kayla oh
and we're in a different neighborhood
we're not even in really quite the same
area Kayla that's suspicious yeah that's
a little and this time you were
appearing at me
to be to be frank
how do you answer these charges Kayla
um
you were on my blog
because I want to preserve both of our
um you know locations which we probably
you go there I go there it's literally
right next door to where I live and I
was walking by to go home and walk my
dog and you walked out and I was like
again are you are you kidding me like
and I started laughing and then you
looked up and I think you were kind of
like all right who is this person and
you kind of said hello and I said sorry
actually we met last week yep and then
you said of course and then we sort of
um started chatting again and I asked
you again for a selfie
you won another one no so we anyway yeah
we're chatting yep what I was gonna say
was what was funny about the first
interaction is I was on the phone with
my friend and she was on the phone the
whole time so when I got off when I left
you guys to go into the restaurant she
was able to tell me line by line what
happened
I'm thinking she had called the police
no wait and it required zero explanation
because you have the most recognizable
voice and so she said that was the most
extraordinary interaction I've ever
accidentally overheard that was funny
but you know it was because then we were
chatting and that's the second time we
ran into each other and I said okay now
we have to have Kayla on the podcast
this will clear up and she refused and
she refused but I know where she lives
um yeah so uh this is just oh it was all
happening it was almost happening and
yeah I was I was very happy I mean
clearly I I love our fans I have great
respect for our fans yeah when you meet
these very smart cool people who like
the podcast I'm I'm a happy happy guy so
uh you know that's it how much did it it
clearly bothered you though she said no
thanks I'm good when you offered her so
I didn't let it go yeah clearly yeah I
promised her a spot on this podcast
that's what we haven't heard is there
was a negotiation yeah she's also
getting four hundred thousand dollars
which I have to wire into a Swiss
account you heard it here listeners you
can extort Conan for money by just
refusing a podcast
no refusing one withhold to selfie and
then demand cash